à la verrie de la rochère cd 1475 que
l'on souffle le vert à l'origine de
cette fabrication des matières premières
régionales la forêt de darnets
fournissait alors le bois la silice et
la fougère nécessaires à cette
production jusqu'au 19ème siècle le vert
résultait en effet de la fusion à fond
violent d'un mélange de silice et de
celle de potasse sous forme de cendres
de lettres de fendre de fougères d'où le
qualificatif de verre de fougères que
mentionne les manuscrits à l'heure
actuelle c'est la silice de la forêt de
nemours qui a pris la relève et permet
l'obtention de vers blancs facilement
coloré ensuite par des oxydes
métalliques
ce qui frappe lorsqu'on pénètre dans cet
univers du feu c'est que toute
l'activité est concentrée autour du
foyer lequel fournit chaque jour 5 à 6
tonnes de verre en fusion sous l'aspect
trompeur d'un fourmillement tous sens le
déplacement de chaque ouvrier porter aux
souffleurs est en réalité calculé de
manière précise
quelques mètres parcourus avec la boule
en fusion entraîne un abaissement de
température de plusieurs degrés qui rend
alors l'objet moins souple et plus
cassant la température de fusion du
verre est d'environ mille quatre cent
cinquante degrés sa température de
travail inférieur de seulement 30 degrés
travail de spécialistes la fabrication
d'un objet de verre est un véritable
travail collectif l'objet fixé au bout
de la canne passe en effet de main en
main tel un véritable flambeau de la
revue c'est l'utilisation combinée de la
pesanteur de la boule en fusion du
souffle du verrier et du contact avec
des outils de bois mouillé qui donne à
l'objet sa forme définitive
une boule souffle et formera le corps du
vert après la pose de la jambe puis du
pied l'ensemble est repris à l'aide d'un
compte ils sortent de cannes plein
préalablement chauffé au rouge afin de
réchauffer dans un petit four la calotte
qui sera ensuite ouverte technique qui
au fil des ans avait disparu au profit
de la mécanisation vatan on ne faisait
pas de choses d'objets ouvert au feu et
c'était des objets tout ouvert à la
machine et
il y a cinq ou six ans nous avons pensé
qu'il fallait plutôt séduit y est vers
les choses plus artisanale et à ce
moment là nous sommes allés demander des
verriers portugais qui le faisait depuis
mi temps ancestraux
alors que les notes avait besoin
d'apprendre puisque nous n'avons pas eu
l'occasion d'en faire et qu'ils ont été
très bien ils ont formé les nôtres
maintenant nous avons un bon groupe de
français qui ouvre fait pour certains
postes de travail l'apprentissage se
poursuit pendant plusieurs mois et ce
n'est qu'après huit à dix ans qu'un
ouvrier verrier est vraiment capable de
reproduire de a à z une pièce quelle
qu'elle soit un certain goût de l'objet
noble et l'esquissé d'une mode rétro à
faciliter la relance ces dix dernières
années de la verrerie artisanat
je pense que plus il ya de choses faites
automatique plus le public sera enclin à
se tourner vers les choses faites à la
main et puis ce serait tout à fait dans
le goût du gouvernement qui trouvent
qu'il faut créer des emplois
l'automatique en supprime l âme à
antonne autrefois l'objet était purement
usuels pensez vous que maintenant
l'objet de verts deviennent vraiment un
objet d'art pour nous dire un objet
d'art non un homme nous nous contentons
de penser que nos objets sont très
agréables maintenant dire que ce sont
des objets d'art se serrer toutes
prétentions que nous n'avons pas 60000
personnes dont l'année dernière visiter
l'usiné son magasin d'exposition les
touristes de cette région vont désormais
une raison supplémentaire de venir à la
rochère puisque une galerie d'art
contemporain sera inaugurée demain des
oeuvres du sculpteur roudaut et de
galard ottenheimer et perrot seront
exposées jusqu'au 8 septembre
l'objectif de cette galerie de
promouvoir l'art contemporain sous
toutes ses formes est d'offrir aussi au
regard des amateurs de notre région
des oeuvres dignes des galeries
parisiennes
[Musique]